um have you ever had a guy have big
thick energy and end up not
his energy not necessarily lining up
with his actual physical uh
situation you know i ain't gonna lie i
i've been blessed in that department um
i feel for my sisters i read y'all
stories on twitter and [ __ ] like i
thought he had big big dick energy and
then we went to his crib and then [ __ ]
kind of was a little disappointing and i
asked like a question like that on
twitter i was like you know like have
you ever been
in a situation where it wasn't big dick
energy and the stories i was reading
child i'm like
baby i'm blessed
i'm blessed
like i feel like i'm blessed
like what like what is the energy you
think because i know i know guys with
little dick energy usually they have
they have like really big trucks or like
um it's just like do too much like it
don't even got to be like a material
thing or like what you own it's just
like a more of a like
personal like
like it's a charisma big big dick energy
is the charisma or uh
personality it's just like how you walk
how you talk it's not even like oh i got
a chain oh i got a ferrari right like
them how are you carriers nine times out
of ten
they got to compensate you know
i can't deal with that little man
syndrome [ __ ] yeah no well you've been
blessed yeah i'm very blessed shout out
to you